For this module,
you'll need to open up the file entitled
lesson eight, Calm the compiler.
And now we're going to play a few
rounds of Calm the compiler.
You'll see a series of
compiler errors and
quiet them by using
the correct protocols syntax.
In this first error, the Minion class
has adopted the dirty deeds protocol.
But the compiler is complaining.
Type minion does not conform
to protocol dirty deeds.
Pause the video.
Take a minute to fix this error.
And then, continue on.
To conform to the dirty deeds protocol,
the Minion class needs to implement
the methods cheat and steal.
So if we add those implementations,
the compiler is happy again.
Let's try another one.
Here we have our DinnerCrew class again,
along with the Souschef protocol.
The goal here is to initialize
a deviousDinnerCrew
with an array of minions.
But we get the following error.
Cannot invoke initializer for
type DinnerCrew with an argument
list of type [members: [Minion].
How can we fix this?
What could be wrong
with the argument list?
Right now, the Minion class does
not adopt the Souschef protocol.
So minions can't be a part
of the deviousDinnerCrew.
If we add the Souschef protocol to
the Minion class definition, and
then implement the methods in
the Souschef protocol, chopped and
rinse, this error goes away.
Let's do one more.
Here, we have the DogWalker protocol.
And the class Neighbor is
adopting this protocol.
We've seen this error before.
Type neighbor does not conform
to protocol DogWalker.
Last time we got this error it
was because we hadn't implemented
the protocol methods yet.
But here you can see that
the methods have been implemented.
What's going on?
Here's what's going on.
The throwBall method signature
in the protocol definition
indicates that throwBall
should return an int.
The throwBall method in the Neighbor
class, on the other hand,
is not returning anything.
If we add the return type int to
neighbor's implementation of throwBall,
and then add the line return count,
the compiler is satisfied.